c'est une des zones les plus
militarisées de la planète
trois mille kilomètres de séparation et
de rivalité entre l'inde et le pakistan
un conflit vieux de 70 entre deux frères
ennemis
un potentiel explosif avec deux pays
armé de la bombe atomique
[Musique]
et pourtant à la frontière
oui
m
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
tous les soirs des milliers de personnes
convergent vers le seul poste frontalier
qui existe entre l'inde et le pakistan
l'endroit est ultra surveillé un
attentat a eu lieu ici il ya quelques
années
pourtant dans les tribunes l'ambiance
est à la fête
on mange de la crème glacée et du pop
quand les haut parleurs diriger vers
l'autre pays
la cérémonie d'affrontements patriotique
peut commencer
[Applaudissements]
le côté pakistanais a aussi ses
supporters comme dans une compétition
sportive
les vedettes du spectacle ce sont de
vrais soldats en noir les pakistanais en
beige les indiens leur crête sur la tête
ne font pas de doute nous assistons à un
combat de coqs
c'est à celui qui lèvera le pied le plus
haut
[Applaudissements]
les soldats se toisent se provoque puis
se salue ils peuvent maintenant faire
descendre les drapeaux le temps d'une
nuit dans un simulacre de paie à la fin
de l' empire des indes en 1947 les
britanniques organisent une séparation
sur des bases religieuses les région
peuplée en majorité de musulmans
formeront le pakistan et c'est la
majorité hindoue deviendront l'inde
mais il ya un problème une principauté
peuplée de musulmans mais dirigée par un
hindou décide de se rattacher à l'inde
70 ans plus tard les deux pays se
disputent toujours le cachemire avec au
passage trois guerres et des
escarmouches fréquentes
[Musique]
quand nous demandons à cet homme ce
qu'il pense de la relation entre les
deux pays